Hey it's me Destin. So here's the deal. If you watch this video it has
the potential to change every day of your life for the rest of your life, however,
you also have the potential to think about me, and whoever sent you this video, every day
when you're alone and half naked. So I'm going to give you three seconds
to think about this.
This is one of those things that affects billions of people all over the world
but nobody talks about it. At least not in an intelligent respectful way.
In 1895 there was a paper published by the London Society for Promoting Christian Knowledge
by a guy named A. M. Worthington. It had to do with splashes, so after
reading that, and looking at some work by a guy named Weber, I got to thinking.
Is there a way we can eliminate what's known as a Worthington jet? Or as I like to call it...
poop splash.
OK if you imagine in your head right now if you were to drop a rock in water,
what happens is a cavity opens up and it's air, and all that air
has nowhere to go so it slaps back together because there's a discontinuity in pressure.
Now if you break it down, surface tension is force per unit length.
(Destin) Nice goggles.
- (Sister- Briley) Thumbs up for science.
(Sister) Sample A. What do you think?
(Destin) [laughs] I don't know
about you but I have never made anything like that with my body.
(Sis) Well I did make
more samples, but it just depends on how much tolerance you have.
(Destin) What does tolerance mean?
(Sis) Tolerance for accuracy if you will.
(Destin) I think we need to scrub accuracy and go for more realism.
(Sis) Hey Dest I got the uh..
(Destin) What's up? We got number two here?
(Destin) Are those beads?
(Sis) Technically.
3..2..1.. drop the deuce
[music]
Pinch the loaf in 3..2..1..
What can we do to eliminate this?
The answer is, vary the surface tension. All you have to do
is grab a piece of toilet paper that's already in the bathroom with you
and lay it on the surface. I like to use
four pieces so that it touches each side. That way it stays in one position.
[music]
It totally caught all the bubbles...
See that?
[music]
(Destin) There you go. That fun?
(Daughter) Are you potty training big people?
(Destin) Yesss. [laugh]
[music]
Alright. In summary, I hope you don't think we were being rude or crude or anything
like that, we're just not that kind of people, we don't uh..
(Sis) Very nice. [laugh]
This affected billions of people and nobody talks about it. Why don't they talk about it?
I don't know, but you're gonna go home and try it and you're gonna...
You're welcome.
(Destin) Don't even act like you're not gonna try it.
(Sis) What we need you
to do is subscribe if you learned, actually, something.
- And probably better, send it to your friends to weird them out.
Cause I think this is pretty weird.
- Me too.
- It's pretty weird but it was pretty awesome.
- If you would like to click on the cat to subscribe...
Can you make that happen?
- I can make that happen.
- Awesome. Do that! Click on the cat!
(Destin) Send this to your friends, word of mouth, so they'll think about you every time they're uh..
(Sister) He's Destin,
You're getting Smarter Every Day. That's it.
You're making fun of me...
[music]
[music by A Shell In the Pit]
[ Captions by Andrew Jackson ]
captionsbyandrew.wordpress.com
Captioning in different languages welcome.
Please contact Destin if you can help.